[Music]
where were you when you learned about
her passing were you in the hotel yes
what do you remember about that moment
shock she and i had just spoken
not even
an hour it hadn't even been an hour
so
i was really
in a great deal of shock
a story not many know monica was
actually with longtime friend vanessa
bryant the night whitney died whitney's
cousin dionne warwick asked the two to
watch over whitney's then 18 year old
daughter bobby christina
i'm sure vanessa's probably never even
shared that she was sitting right there
being
in the hotel that night the only person
i trusted to even tell me what to do or
where to go
was dion miss dion when she said you
stay here
you're the only person i want to keep
chrissy stay here that's what i did i do
is told for those that i know i can
trust and vanessa never left my side
years later when tragedy struck in
vanessa's life monica would be there for
her it's an everyday struggle when you
lose your husband
and a child and it is just my job when
people have been there for me the way
vanessa has if you go back whether it
was good or bad she was standing beside
me
she was there
but in february of 2012 just two days
before she passed it was whitney
providing the support for monica and
brandi whitney's proteges were getting
ready to perform at clive davis's
pre-grammy party she was in and out of
our rehearsals
she kept touching my face and
just telling me
you got it don't worry about it doesn't
matter who's watching
you you're the greatest of the great i'm
a fairy godmother and that's so cool
you're cool with that i'm cool with that
she would always tell me like
you forget who you are
that's a mistake
don't let them make you forget
i try to inspire you know what i'm
saying let people
you know their hearts
that was the greatest lesson from her
is that
i matter
is that i'm important
and she's always telling me don't let
them change who you are
i think she could see in me
that i forget
i just forget that sometimes
sometimes i give more to people
than i give to myself
[Applause]
[Music]
in the
[Music]
[Applause]
in some of the most difficult of times
whitney could have been anywhere but she
would show up
right when i was 18 i lost my
grandmother i lost i witnessed the
suicide i lost my cousin whitney didn't
call on the phone
three black trucks pulled up in the hood
and she jumped out this forever etched
in my mind and in my heart
[Applause]
whitney's memory lives on for monica in
her work she has a new single ready to
drop soon her new album trenches is due
out this year and she's hosting her talk
show motoc but her fairy godmother is
never far from her thoughts
what do you think whitney's legacy
should be the fact
is no voice
has come close
no one sacrificed as much as she did if
you go back
and you look at one of my favorite
photos of she and i
i'm holding her stomach
but that baby didn't survive
people don't realize exactly what she
experienced she lost a baby around the
time of the bodyguard there were
multiple times where
she was self-sacrificing
for our entertainment
you can't disrespect a woman that gives
that much and you can't change that no
one's touched
who she is and what she was and how
she's saying
ever since
[Music]
you